craig
mostchau
why shouldn't the dolphins just take
justin fields at six if he's there if
he's bad tua is fine if he's amazing you
have another asset more valuable than
any other rookie this takes best
available player to the extreme we got a
quarterback but the best guy on our
boards another quarterback let's just go
another quarterback like jimmy johnson
in 89 when he used a first round
supplemental pick on steve walsh just
months after he drafted troy aikman
shireen should they do that
well i'm not sold on tua they seem to be
sold on two i guess if you've seen
enough from him and practiced to say
he's your quarterback you try to build
around him right but
since i'm not sold on two i absolutely
would do that if i think justin fields
is a really good quarterback my scouts
have scouted him and say he's going to
be a great quarterback absolutely i
would do that i just think you double
your chances of having a franchise guys
we talked about for possibly the next 15
to 20 years if two is not the guy then
maybe this is the guy right instead of
being back in the quarterback market
next year or the year after you have
your guide maybe you're not drafting
that high next year or the year after
you look at what the lions did last year
at number three overall they didn't
draft justin herbert and now they are
where they are with jared goff as their
quarterback so absolutely that's what i
would do but i'm not the dolphins and i
think they're sold on to us so i think
they have no plans to do that mike
this would be the ultimate smokescreen
all-in move jedi mind trick if you're
the dolphins and you're sitting at three
and and have any quarterback that you
can get other than trevor lawrence and
presumably zach wilson drop to 12 jump
to six create the impression you're
there to get one of the top non
quarterbacks and then take fields
if fields is there that would be awesome
but i i just i don't see that happening
they would have stayed at three if they
liked fields that much stay at three and
get him i think they want to give two uh
another year and by picking up the extra
first rounder
that they acquired
in that that trade down trade back up
because they gave up one of the first
rounders to the eagles but they still
have a net first rounder going into next
year out of the transaction that can be
a piece that they use to move up next
year if they decide to get in better
position to get a quarterback so i
understand the thinking i just think the
moment they traded out a three
the quarterback possibility evaporated
unless they really are up to something
that would be genius
that would be awesome too wouldn't it
but you look at all the teams mike the
year they passed on on dan marino for
instance joe montana for instance i know
the cowboys did that because they said
hey we have our quarterback we're
passing on this guy and look what dan
marino and joe montana turned out to be
so that's my only reservation with
passing on a quarterback if you truly
think that guy's gonna be a franchise
guy i just don't know that you pass on
him
by the way our new nbc colleague drew
brees told rich eisen yesterday that it
wasn't just 2006 when the dolphins
passed on brees the dolphins led brees
to believe that they were taking him in
the low 20s in 2001 they took jamar
fletcher cornerback instead when brees
thought he was going to get the call
because obviously at the time they were
still in their post dan marino who the
heck is our quarterback going to be so
they passed on brees sorry dolphins fans
but it's the truth not once but twice
ed's dubbot
i think that's what it is easy dubbit
easy dubbett maybe that's it what is the
lines for i don't know what is the
lion's first round selection worth trade
value if justin fields is on the board
at number seven now
you know this is complicated because one
of the big factors is
how far down are you going because
obviously there's going to be a
flip-flop of picks are you flipping
seven and eight with the panthers are
you flipping seven and nine with the
broncos are you flipping seven and
fifteen with the patriots who are you
flipping with at number seven and i
think how far down you go
dictates necessarily how much more that
team has to give up shireen it's that
simple
and i'm not so sure if jessa fields is
there that i'm not going to draft justin
fields if i if i've scouted him and i
think he's going to be again a franchise
quarterback if i'm the lions i may take
him
certainly could be better than jared
goff as jared goff your quarterback of
the future brad holmes seems to like him
but again he's not a guy i'm sold on as
being their future at the quarterback
position and we saw it last year when
they passed on justin herbert so they
have an opportunity here if justin
fields is here to draft perhaps their
quarterback of the future so i'm not
trained down if i'm the lions i'm taking
him
also with chris spielman now in a
position of significant influence in
that organization he's got a big old
spoon
in the stew that is the lions
organization
what's he gonna do when an ohio state
guy
is smiling at him at number seven is he
gonna be able to set that aside right is
he gonna be able to set that aside
because i know somebody who if she was a
special adviser to sheila fordham and
texas a m guy is smiling at them at
number seven shireen williams isn't
going to say no to texas a m guy and
that leads into our next question jr the
boss man how does texas a m great kellen
monde to tennessee sound to you he could
grow and develop behind texas a m great
ryan tannehill
well i you know i think that'd be a good
spot for him to go learn from ryan's
hannah hill right i think
you know when i first started asking
scouts about calamond and what they
thought about him
probably into his senior year so
sometime during the fall last year they
set fourth round this guy's not gonna
last till the fourth round i think he's
probably going to go in the second round
maybe the third round but i quarterbacks
always go higher than we think right and
i do have questions about his
consistency his accuracy but he's played
a lot of football and he's played a lot
of sec football and he's won a lot of
sec games they were 9-1 this past season
so you have to say something for that he
ran a complicated pro-style offense and
he ran it really well for jimbo fisher
he's taking a lot of snaps under center
so he's done a lot of things you look
for in a quarterback so i think he's
going to go somewhere and i think he
he's going to be a decent starter or a
really good backup for somebody but it
would behoove him to go somewhere where
he can sit i think for a year mike and
learn even though he has all that
experience i still think it's better for
those young guys to go sit most of the
time
and remember the sims quarterback
rankings this year goes zach wilson
trevor lawrence mack jones and not
justin fields not trey lance but kellen
monde at number four and he says that
phil sims turned him on to calamond
during the season and he started paying
attention to him and he believes that
that monde is again ahead of fields and
lance by way of overall prospect value
so we'll see where mond ends up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports